but first the president knows that the
democrats are taking on political water
after for months excusing these riotous
events across the country they called
them protests for the longest period of
time
but they went into massive looting that
did enormous destruction from
some of our most beautiful cities in the
united states
and he took their pathetic and
transparent
shift attempt to blame shift to
president trump
he took that on tonight
in the strongest possible terms the
republican party condemns the rioting
looting arson and violence we have seen
in democrat-run cities all
like kenosha minneapolis portland
chicago and new york joe biden and his
supporters
remain completely silent about the
rioters and criminals
spreading mayhem in democrat-run cities
they never
even mentioned it during their entire
convention
never once mentioned now they're
starting to mention it
because their poll numbers are going
down like a rocking water
i mean you saw that today right so joe
biden and
his vice president uh kamala harris came
out today and suddenly started
condemning
the violence well where were they last
week they had an entire convention
last week they didn't mention the
violence once except to
kind of very blandly refer to protests
and the courageous protests
but the attempt to lay the destruction
in those cities at the feet of donald
trump
he wasn't going to stand for that at all
look um
if you think about it donald trump
saying uh you're not going to be safe in
joe biden's america all the video being
played is being played in donald trump's
america
these guys are rooting for violence
that's what it's all about you think the
president of the united states is
rooting for the violence because he
thinks it helps him politically
i think he views it as a political
benefit it's just laughable mayors and
governors from minnesota to wisconsin to
oregon washington
they've denied the president's attempts
to bring calm to our streets
they rejected it all together so are
these the leaders that we want to turn
the keys of the country over to
they're all supporting biden they're all
voting for biden the ones who engage in
this disgusting political calculation
so they're putting partisan interests
above the safety
of our people well trump doesn't need
political wins to push him in the right
position
he's always been there your vote will
decide whether we protect law-abiding
americans
or whether we give free rein to violent
anarchists and agitators and criminals
who threaten our citizens
now to drive that point home the
president asked
an important question tonight watch
at the democrat national convention joe
biden and his party repeatedly assailed
america as a land of racial economic
and social injustice
so tonight i ask you a simple question
how can the democrat party ask to lead
our country
when it spends so much time tearing down
our country to the west
well the answer is they can't and they
shouldn't but the left is obsessed with
power
and as the president said tonight
they'll try to get it back by any means
necessary
and unlike president trump who puts the
people's interests first
they put their political interests first
and this is why
they want to try to take the reins of
power from him
from the moment i left my former life
behind
and it was a good life
i have done nothing but fight for you
i did what our political establishment
never expected
and could never forgive breaking the
cardinal rule of washington politics
i kept my promise and america is a
better country because those
promises were fulfilled